bear markets are really scary things and
the price of all financial assets seem
to be falling off a cliff people are
running around there's fear chaos and
uncertainty all over the place i
recently saw a twitter thread from raul
paul the founder of real vision in which
he clearly articulated a lot of how i'm
thinking i thought we could go right
through it he started with macro views
as i've talked a lot about i think we're
going into a pretty nasty recession or
we're already in one layoffs are coming
as are house prices falling demand
destruction is everywhere due to the
largest monetary tightening in history
raul then went on to say the equity
markets have priced this already the
credit markets are beginning to price
this and copper is doing its job it's
the year-over-year rate change in these
assets you need to look at the bond
market and oil are the two assets not
pricing in future recession yet bonds
finally decided to join the party and
the trend of higher yields lower
equities has probably ended lower stocks
now equal lower yields the final show to
add to this will be oil he thinks that
it breaks lower bond yields falling and
oil falling will give the excuse to the
fed to hike in may and then pause and
maybe do one more in june then bond
markets will then begin to price it out
however the next four weeks are going to
be highly unsettling and every position
gets taken out and shot there will be no
safe place to hide except for bonds but
most people are short those liquidation
all over the place
crypto it's in full panic mode all the
monkeys are flinging poo at each other
or at raul on twitter and that's a sign
of approaching the lows march 2020 was
very similar in levels of fear anger
vitriol shock and panic june 2021 was
less but crypto's a long-term investment
by raul it's not a trade in the thesis
in clear expectations of 60 corrections
without that kind of volatility you
don't get the exponential upside if you
zoom out from the fud you get bitcoin
heading back to its long-term
exponential moving average tough times
like these are times to buy if you have
any spare cash that's not necessarily
easy these days and sentiment is so bad
that you just by writing the tweets that
will get people in the comment section
full of personal attacks vitriol and
anger he's sorry you feel that way bear
markets and recessions are hard and
scary but they give huge opportunities
keep calm carry on stick to the
frameworks relentlessly test your
hypothesis keep an open mind filter out
the noise and focus opportunity comes
out of crisis
he's looking to add an eath and getting
wildly bullish bonds and he's averaging
in to high beta growth regardless of
what you think happens there's lots of
great advice in that twitter threat the
louder that the fear gets the latter the
uncertainty and the chaos gets the more
opportunity there probably is one of the
hardest parts in investing is actually
controlling your emotions when everyone
else is fearful you've got to start to
get a little greedy and ultimately what
we are watching is that markets are just
full of sheep as people get scared other
people get more and more scared and it
has this negative feedback loop
ultimately i don't think that bitcoin or
other types of financial assets will go
down forever the question is just when
does the pain stop and no one actually
knows but one thing that you have to do
in any asset class real estate stocks
bonds crypto or anything else
keep a long time horizon and make sure
that you always ensure that you've got
durability to your financial portfolio